so first
we are going to talk about relational
classification and
iterative classification so let me
explain you uh the ideas
uh for this part of the lecture so
first we want to talk about what is a
relational classification
then we'll talk about iterative
classification and then last
i'm going to talk about belief
propagation as i as i said
earlier so probabilistic relational
classifier the idea is the following
the class probability y sub v of node v
is a weighted average of class
probabilities of its neighbors
right so this means that for labeled
nodes we are going to fix
their class label to be the ground truth
label the label we are given
and then for um unlabeled nodes we are
just initialize
their belief that let's say they are
they have the color green
to be let's say 0.5 so something uniform
and then nodes are going to update their
belief about what color they are about
based on the on the colors of the
nodes uh in the network around them and
this is going to iterate
until it converges and just to note
here we are only going to use node
labels
and network structure but we are not yet
going to use
node attributes so here this works even
if nodes
only have colors and there are no
attributes
attached to the nodes or no features
attached to the nodes
so how are we going to do this update we
are going to
update this formula that i that i show
that i show here
and the idea is the following we say
that probability that my node of
interest v
is of class c is simply
1 over the sum over let's say the
weights
of the edges um uh that that are
adjacent to our node v
so this is basically uh counts the
degree
or the in degree of node v um and then
we say
now let's sum up over this same set of
edges
here is the weight of every edge times
the probability that the neighbor
belongs to the same class c so basically
here we are summing all the neighboring
nodes
u of node v we ask what is the weight of
the edge
times the probability the likelihood
that node u belongs to class c
so basically what this is saying is that
the node
v says the the likelihood that i belong
to a given class c is the
average likelihood that my neighbors
belong to that
same class c and that's it right so in
some sense here
a node is going to update its belief or
prediction about its own label
about the beliefs or predictions about
the labels of its nearby nodes and here
we are making the most basic assumption
which is that
the two nodes share a label if they are
connected in the in the network which is
here and you know we can now think of
auv as a zero one kind of as an
unweighted graph or we can think of this
as a weight
um and then you know now different nodes
you have different
influence on the label of v because of
the
different connection strength and this
is just a normalization
so that this weighted summation uh is
between
zero and one there are a few just
important things to note
is that convergence of this formula is
not guaranteed
and also notice as i said this model
cannot use
node feature information it is just
using the labels of the nodes
and also uses the network information
how does it use
the network information it uses it
because these summations go over the
edges or over the neighbors
in the network that's how network
information is used
so let me give you now an example how
one could go and
implement this simple method first you
know we are going to
initialize all labeled nodes with their
true labels and we are going to fix this
so these probabilities of green and red
nodes
remain fixed right it says node 7
belongs to green class with probability
while the node 2 belongs to green class
with probability 0
because it's red right and then all the
unlabeled nodes here
we will assign their probability to
belonging to
to class uh green to the positive class
to be
uh to be 0.5 right nodes are unde
undecided
which class they wanna uh belong to so
now what we are going to do is we are
going to
update the this probabilities p
of the gray nodes so let me show you how
we are going to do this
um of course when we will be doing this
we need to come up with some
order in which we are going to update
the nodes and in our case
let's assume that our order is exactly
based on node id so it's one two three
four five
and so on so first we are going to
update node three
and node three says the following it
says aha
i have uh three neighbors um you know
um and uh how how am i going uh to do
this
i have um you know uh the the
two neighbors of me have the probability
zero of belonging to the green class
and this uh and i have one grey grey
member that has 0.5
so this is 0 0 plus 0.5 and because i
have three neighbors and my graph is
unweighted so this is divided by three
so now
the the node number three has a
probability of belonging to green class
uh of point seventeen now there is you
know now node four wakes up
and we are going to update its own uh
predicted probability of
being green and again it goes over its
four
neighbors and we sum up a zero uh this
is because of this one
then we sum up point seventeen point
five
and one and divided by four so the
node number four will say my likelihood
or my probability that i am
um labeled green is point four two
now um now that node four has uh
updated its label then node five is
going to update its label
again summing over its neighbors uh and
you know it will
it will come up with a belief that its
probability of being green is 0.73
then you know node 8 is going to update
its label and node 9 is going to update
its label
and after you know the first iteration
updates of all the unlabeled nodes
these are our uh beliefs our predicted
probabilities of them being
green again the the pre-labeled nodes
they don't get to update they remain
fixed
and all the gray nodes get to update and
you for example node number nine
thinks it's green because the only
neighbor it has is green with
probability one so
nine is also very sure it's uh it's
green
um while for example the the eighth is a
bit less because it has one node who is
not
neighboring one node node number five
and that node is not
super entirely sure about its color yet
so this is
uh one iteration now we do the second
iteration when now again
node three is going to to update its by
summing zero zero
zero zero um and point four two and
dividing it by three
so what is going to happen is this
probability increases a bit more
then you know note 4 updated itself five
updated
uh and eight updated and nine updated
but its probability didn't change so we
say not note 9 has converged it
converged to
its belief and that's how it will stay
so now you notice how the
beliefs have changed across the network
and now i can
run this for another uh iteration where
again
i update nodes in the order three four
five
eight and as i update them uh you know
the
probabilities updated a bit again uh but
node 8
did not change its uh probability so we
say it converged and we fix it
right so now i still have three nodes
and i will update this for another
iteration
right um and in the other iteration the
four
five and three don't change so they have
also convert so now
uh node three believes it's of green
class with probability point sixteen
um five thinks it's point uh eight six
so quite high
and then you know node number four is
undetermined it thinks it's a bit
leaning a bit more towards green
but it's uh but it's unclear so
um if i run for one more iteration um
then the probabilities um on this
classification task will converge
here is what are the values they
converge to so what do we conclude
we conclude that 9 8 and 5
belong belong to green class
node 4 also belongs to green clash
because it's just above 0.5 but very
slightly
so 4 is also green and 3 says
you know i have a very low belief that i
am of green color
so 3 is of red color right so our
predictions now would be that
four four five uh eight and nine belong
to
uh green color and three belongs to uh
red color
and we did this by basically just doing
this um iterative classification by
propagating this label information
and notes updating its belief about its
label
based on the labels of other nodes so in
this approach
we used the notion of the network but we
did not use the notion
that nodes have any kind of features or
any kind of
signal attached to them so
this was in terms of relational
classification
based on the labels alone and you saw
how basically
the the probabilities kind of spread
from labeled nodes to unlabeled nodes
through this um through this iterative
classification
when nodes were updating uh the
probabilities based on the probabilities
of their
nearby nodes or their neighbors in the
network
so now we are going to look at the
iterative
classification a different kind of type
of approach
that will use more of the information in
particular it's going to use both the
node features
as well as the labels of the nearby
nodes so this will now
combine both the network as well as the
the feature information of the nodes so
in the relational classifiers that we
have just talked about
they do not use node attributes they
just use the network structure
and the labels so now the question is
how do we label
how do we take advantage how do we
harness
the information in node attributes
and the main idea of iterative
classification is
to classify node v based on its
attributes f
as well as the labels z of the
neighboring nodes n sub v of this
node v of interest
so how is this going to work on the
input we are given a graph
each node will have a feature vector
associated with it
and some nodes will be labeled with
labels y
the task is to predict labels of
unlabeled nodes
and the way we are going to do this is
that we are going to train
two classifiers we are going first to
train a base classifier that is going to
predict
a label of a node based on its feature
vector
alone that's the classifier phi 1
and then we are also going to train
another classifier
that will have two inputs it will have
inputs about the features
of node v and it is also
going to have this additional input this
vector z
that will summarize the labels
of these neighbors so this means that
now we are
making predictions with this classifier
phi 2
um using two in two types of input one
is the feature information
uh captured in this feature vector f and
also the labels of the name of its
neighbors
captured in the vector z
and this way this approach will now be
using both the feature information
as well as the network information
so let me tell you now how do we compute
this
label summary vector z of of our given
node v so the idea will be that
you know i'm a given node here in the
network let's say blue
and i have some nodes that believe they
are green and other nodes that believe
they are red
so now what i need is to create this
this this
summary vector z uh that will tell me
how what are the beliefs what are what
does my what do my neighbors
think about their labels so for example
there are many
choices i can make to deter to set this
uh vector uh z for example i could
simply have it to be a vector
to be a histogram which would count the
number
or the fraction of each label in the
neighborhood so for example in this case
um for this node the blue node we could
say aha
i have two neighbors who think they are
green and i have one neighbor
who thinks it's red or another way would
be to say
you know 66 percent of my neighbors
think they are green and 33 think they
are red and this is what this
vector z would capture we could also for
example
extend z to say what is the most common
label
among these neighbors or how many
different labels are among
these neighbors but essentially here the
idea is that this vector z
captures how the labels
around the node of interest v are
are distributed among the neighbors
of node v in the network and there are a
lot of different
uh choices uh how we come up
uh how how we can come up with this
vector
um so these iterative classifiers are
going
now to work in two steps in the first
step or in the first
phase we are going to classify node
labels
based on node attributes alone so it
means using the training data
we are going to train two classifiers
for example using a linear classifier a
neural network or
support vector machine or a decision
tree that given a feature vector of a
given node
it's going to predict its label and in
phase one we are going to apply this
classifier phi 1
so that now every node in the network
has some predicted
label and then using the training data
we are also going to
train this classifier phi 2 that is
going to use two inputs it's going to
use the feature
of the node of interest as well as this
summary vector z
that captures or summarizes the labels
of the nodes in its network
neighborhood and this phi 2 is going to
predict the label of the node of
interest v
based on its features as well as the
summary z
of its of the labels of its neighbors
and then right so we have first applied
phi
one then we also have trained phi two so
that now we will
go into phase two where we are going to
iterate
and we are going to iterate until
convergence uh the following
uh the following um iteration where on
the
test set which means on the unlabeled
nodes
we are going to use this first the
classifier phi 1
to assign initial labels we are going to
compute the
label summaries z and then we are going
to predict the labels
with the second classifier phi 2 and we
are going now to repeat this process
until it converges in a sense that we
are going to update
the vector z we are going to apply the
classifier phi 2
to update the label of the node and
now the node labels have updated we are
going to
update the label summary z and again
apply phi 2 to update the node pretty
the the node predictions
update z update the prediction and keep
iterating this
until this class labels stabilize
converge or some maximum number of
iterations
is reached um note that in general or in
worst case
convergence is not guaranteed so we
would set some maximum
number of iterations you know maybe 10
50 100
something like that not too many not too
many
so that's the idea
so what i want to do next is actually
show you this
to give you a sense how this work on a
simple toy example so the idea here is
that we have an input graph
let's say that we are thinking about web
pages so we have a graph of how web
pages link to each other
each node will be a web page an edge
will be a hyperlink
between the web pages and
we will have a directed edge which means
that one page
points to another page and imagine that
every node in my network
is is a is described with the set of
features
in our case you know we could simply
assume that this features captures
uh what words what text a web page is
using
and imagine that the task we want to do
is to predict
the topic of the web page and what we
would like to do in this prediction is
use
two facts first is of course we'd like
to use the words of the web page
to predict the topic and then the second
thing we would like to do is
we also can assume that pages that are
on similar topics or on the same topic
they tend to link one another so when we
make a prediction about the topic of a
page
we don't only rely on the words that the
page uses itself but we also want to
rely
on the labels on the topics of the pages
that link to this page of interest
so that is the idea this is what we
would like
to do so let me now uh
show you how how this would work in this
example of web page classification
so the idea here is that first we are
going to train this
uh baseline classifier this classifier
phi uh one that is going to
uh to use uh and classify pages classify
nodes
based on their attributes so just to
give you
uh to explain what what is happening
here we have this
graph on four nodes um
we will do the following it's the color
will denote the ground truth color so
this is the ground truth
topic of the real topic of the web page
um the the then each each page
also has some feature feature vector
let's say describing the words on that
page and let's assume these are the
feature vectors
of my four pages four the pages also
have hyperlinks
uh that are directed and point to each
other
and then for example based on the
labeled data we can
apply our phi 1 and phi 1 will say ah
this
this web page belongs to topic 0 and you
know the ground root is 0 so this is a
correct classification
but for example this this web page here
based on its features alone we will
predict that it is
of topic zero but in reality is it is of
topic one
and the question will be can we using
kind of
network information could network
information help us
to decide that this should really be
green topic not
the red topic as it is predicted based
on the features alone and then you know
we have these two other pages
here are their corresponding feature
vectors um and
you know here the classifier would
predict that they are both green
um while uh here the classifier would
predict that these two should be red
and perhaps you know one way to think of
this is that it's really whether the
first feature
is set to one you are red and if it's
set to zero
you are green that would be one way to
think of the what the classifier is
learning
so now in the first step of this or in
the first phase
um we we came up with predictions of the
labels
uh based only on the features alone so
we applied
the classifier phi uh one
from the previous from the previous
slide so now
what we're going to do next is we want
to create our
fit label summary vectors z
so for each node v we are going to
create this vector z
that captures the neighborhood labels
and given that this is a directed graph
we are going to use
a four-dimensional vector to capture the
statistics
basically we are going to have two parts
to this vector z a part i
and o i is about incoming and o
is about outgoing uh neighbor label
information
and we will say that for example i
of zero is set one if at least one of
the incoming
pages one of the pages that links to
this node of interest
is also labeled zero and uh you know we
will use similar definitions for i1
0 and 01 so give you an idea
so this is now same graph as before
these are the features of the web page
but now this four more numbers appear
here and
let me again explain what do they mean
so this is now these four numbers
are basically my vector
z that summarizes the labels of the
neighbors around it and we have
i which is for incoming neighbors i want
to say
is any of the incoming neighbors of
class 0
class 1 because
this node here has one neighbor that is
green we set
value one here right it's an incoming
neighbor
um and then on the on the uh outgoing
neighbor side
uh this is this edge we have one
neighbor that believes
its class is zero so uh
here it is right uh so notice that
colors correspond to ground truth
and numbers correspond to predicted
labels
right so that's why here i have a one
zero because um
the node of interest has one outgoing
edge to a node
of uh class zero and has zero outgoing
edges
to nodes of class one of the green class
uh similarly for example you can look at
this node here
uh its feature vector and then the
summary of the
incoming edges and the summary of the
outgoing edges this
uh this node has um uh here has
one incoming neighbor that is of class
zero this is this one and has zero
incoming edges
of class one and uh in terms of the
outgoing edges it has zero
outgoing edges to class to class zero
and it has one
outgoing edge to class one so this is
now
you know the four dimensional
representation
uh the vector z the summary of the
labels around this particular node
analogously you can compute it for this
node then you can compute it for that
node
so now that you have for every node both
the vector
f and the vector z uh what
what you do you now train um the second
classifier and again you only train it
on the labeled training set
and this classifier you train in such a
way that it uses both the
information in f as well as the
information in z
so now you are basically uh training
the classifier phi 2 that uses both the
feature information
as well as the label summary information
uh
about what do the neighbors of a node of
interest
think about their own labels and this
now
gives me the classifier phi 2.
so now um in the second step i'm going
now to apply
my classifier phi 2 on the on the graph
of interest on the unlabeled nodes
so right so we i'm going to use trained
node features to apply the classifier
file 1
on the unlabeled unlabeled set
and i'm going to predict the labels and
now
um now i'm going to use trained node
feature vectors
as well to to predict the labels and now
given the predicted labels
i'm going to update the feature
descriptors
the feature descriptors in a in a sense
of class
summaries around each node
now that i have created this vector z i
can now apply
my classifier phi 2 to update the
predicted label
of every node and if i do this
the labels of certain nodes may change
and basically the idea is right now that
i have used all these data meaning the
feature vector
as well as the summary vector of the
labels around the given node
i will be able to more robustly predict
the label of the node of interest
and now right i basically the idea is
that
now i can go and update the summaries
because some labels might have changed
i update the summary and reapply the
fight to
uh predictor phi 2 classifier and i keep
doing this
uh basically reclassifying nodes with
phi 2
until the process converges
right so i'll be updating this until
until the
label prediction stabilize i think
because
if a prediction for a given node changes
then its vector z is also going to
change
and if the vector z go is going changes
then the
i have to apply the predictor phi 2
to update the belief or the prediction
about
the label of a given node and i keep
iterating this
until the process uh stabilizes right so
here
the prediction for this node uh flipped
from zero to one
now these vectors z have changed
have been updated so i have to re-update
my classifier phi
2 again over all these nodes
and i keep doing this until the process
converges meaning until no
node labels change or until some maximum
number of iterations is reached
and that is essentially the idea of what
we are trying to do here
and how do we arrive to the final
prediction so to summarize
so far we have talked about two
approaches to collective classification
first we talked about relational
classification
where we are iteratively updating
probabilities of nodes belonging to a
label class
based on the labels of its neighbors
this approach
inc uses the network structure and the
labels of the nodes
but it does not use the features of
the nodes so then
in the second part we talked about
iterative classification
where we improve over the
relational classification to handle
attribute or feature information
of nodes as well and here the idea was
that we classify
a given node v or a given node i based
on its features
as well as the labels of its neighbors
so here
the way we achieved this was to train
two classifiers
the initial classifier that given the
features of a node predicts its label
now that the nodes have its labels
predicted
we for every node we can now create this
summary vector z
that describes uh the labels
of the nodes that are neighbors of a
node of interest
and then that we have that we can then
use the classifier phi 2 to re-update
the prediction on a given node that and
this classifier phi 2 uses both the
feature information of the node as well
as the summary vector of the labels of
its neighbors
the summary vector z and we then keep
applying this
classifier phi 2 over the network
until the entire process converges
or until the entire the maximum number
of iterations
is reached